la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
de sa passion pour les bonbons elle en a
fait une véritable vocation à la tête
d'une entreprise artisanale de
confiserie peggy laurent maîtrise sur le
bout des doigts
la fabrication de ces douceurs pays
comme aujourd'hui celle des chamallows
donc on va faire ce qu'on appelle des
guimauves ou plus communément connu sous
le nom de chamallow donc aujourd'hui on
va essayer des guimauves coco au cacao
et sinon bah après il existera dans la
gamme plusieurs variétés dont le
géranium enfin des traditionnels d'avec
des parfums de la réunion glacier pour
réussir ces délicieuses friandises
peggy utilise des ingrédients de base
simples pour la production de chamallows
en fait il va nous falloir de la
gélatine du sucre de l'eau et on va
faire cuire tout ça le mélange est et on
va obtenir des chamallows moelleux donc
c'est parti et pendant que la gélatine
gonfle dans l'eau froide tout doucement
peggy garnir un moule pour la
préparation finale on répartit bien le
coco à l'intérieur du moule donc ce qui
nous permettra donc d'avoir un enrobage
on va en remettre après une fois qu'on
aura terminé donc notre préparation et à
la fin on va rouler complètement les
guimauves quand elles sont découpées
dans le coco qu'on aura du coco sur
toutes les faces la cuisson d'un sirop
de sucre lors de la phase suivante doit
alors se faire de manière très précise
au degré près sur un bonbon qui va
rester moonlight sur un suc un sucre dit
au boulet c'est une température qui va
de 116 à 125 degrés environ
donc en fonction de la préparation
ensuite donc on peut obtenir avec sa du
chamallow des caramels mous
si on veut ne puissons plus important
donc sur des pastilles par exemple le
moment traditionnel
là on va être plutôt sur du 150 degrés
162 qu'on ne tient pas à sucre au casse
et voilà qu'ils sont c'est température
de pouce quand le sirop de sucre était
en fait la bonne température
peggy rajoute alors la gélatine avant
d'errer la préparation au batteur
électrique c'est l'aération qui va de
mieux en mieux
car à carouge ge
pour finir on va ajouter donc une petite
préparation au cacao
donc c'est du cacao fondu donc pour
marbré et de lui donner une petite
coloration et puis dû donner aussi bien
sûr un parfum chocolat
il ne reste plus alors qu'à verser
délicatement la préparation dans un
moule et d'être un peu patient
voilà donc après on attend à peu près
quatre heures que ça prenne en fait que
ça refroidisse et que ça prenne donc de
la gélatine fasse son effet et on va
pouvoir passer à l'étape du découpage
donc on a encore des côtes et qui sont
un petit peu collant donc c'est le côté
gélatine
donc on va ensuite les enrobés dans un
mélange de sucre glace et de fécule de
manioc quand même
elles l'avouent sans rougir son péché
mignon c'est les bonbons après avoir
travaillé dans le développement de
logiciels informatiques
c'est presque naturellement que peggy
laurent décide de créer voici quelques
années sa propre entreprise de
confiserie artisanale
c'est l'idée de créer quelque chose à
partir de nos fruits de la réunion de
les mettre en valeur sur des recettes un
petit peu de nouvelles portes et un peu
de nouveauté un petit peu sur tout ça et
donc voilà donc ça a démarré par pas
grand chose quelques moules de sucettes
et des sucettes aromatisé au sirop de
fruit et puis voilà on est à une gamme
maintenant de plus de 14 produits
distribués un petit peu partout sur
l'île qui commence à s'exporter vers la
métropole aussi un petit peu après la
réalisation des chamallows peggy comment
ce matin là celle de grands classiques
de la confiserie française
c'est quelque chose de vraiment pays
avec des parfums ici donc on va
travailler sur des berlingots à la
vanille
alors pour les berlingots à la vanille
il nous faut des extraits de vanille
bien sûr pour le parfum il nous faudra
aussi du sucre alors là c'est un sucre
en bray un petit peu plus foncé que le
sucre traditionnel et une publique aux
âmes
le mélange de sirop de sucre et de
glucose est alors mis à cuire jusqu'à
atteindre la bonne température
on atteint donc notre température de
cuisson
+352 donc on va mettre notre extrême
et nos armes sont bien mélanger on va
déposer donc notre messe de sucre à
refroidir sur une inte appui en silicone
tout en refroidissant lentement la masse
cuite et pétri malaxer travailler et guy
obtient ici un ruban de pâtes satiné
après tout dépend si on met des
colorants votre de coloration différente
du sucre travail et d'avoir donc un
sucre blanc va retrouver du blanc se
méfie un peu de colorant bien sûr vous
allez avoir des couleurs du col rond une
prix là donc sur notre sucre en bray
donc on a le coating ambre et du sucre
qui remonte il ne reste plus alors qu'à
façonner et à découper d'être une leçon
de pâte pour obtenir enfin de délicieux
berlingo à la vanille pays en personne
ça va former les berlingo c'est assez
simple après il faut juste être rapide
parce que la masse de sucre froid y est
quand même assez rapidement à la vanille
comme aujourd'hui ou bien encore parfumé
au café ou au rhum peggy confectionne
ses berlingo pays mais aussi des
sucettes et des bonbons aux saveurs
locales au coco à la mangue ou bien
encore aux fruits de la passion
un vrai régal pour les petits et des
grands gourmands dernière fall qu'on
emballe nos petits maux monde
grâce à chine ont fait les petites cages
et c'est pour pour la boutique
on
et toi
dans